one of the things that might help speed
up your learning algorithm is to slowly
reduce your learning rate over time we
call this learning rate decay let's see
how you can implement this let's start -
an example of why you might want to
implement learning rate decay
suppose you're implementing mini batch
gradient descent with a reasonably small
mini batch maybe a mini batch has just
64 128 examples then as you iterate your
steps will be a little bit noisy and it
will tend toward this minimum over here
but it won't exactly converge but your
algorithm might just end up wandering
around and never really converge because
you're using some fixed value for alpha
and there's just some noise in your
different mini batches but if you were
to slowly reduce your learning rate
alpha then during the initial phases
while your learning rate alpha still
lasts you can still have it to be fast
learning but then as alpha gets smaller
your steps you take would be slower and
smaller and so you end up oscillating in
a tighter region around this minimum
rather than one ring far away even as
training goes on and on so the intuition
behind slowly reducing alpha is that
maybe during the initial steps of
learning you can afford to take much
bigger steps but then as learning
approaches convergence then having a
slower learning rate allows you to take
smaller steps so here's how you can
implement learning rate decay recall
that one epoch is one class through the
data right so if you have them a
training set as follows maybe break it
up into different mini batches then once
the first pass through the training set
is called the first epoch and then the
second pass is the second epoch and so
on so one thing you could do is set your
learning rate alpha to be equal to one
over one plus a per hour
originally called the decay rate times
the epoch num and there's going to be
times some initial learning rate alpha
zero
note that the decay rate here it becomes
another hyper parameter which you might
need to tune so here's a concrete
example um if you take several epochs so
several passes through your data if
alpha zero is equal to zero point two
and the decay rate is equal to one then
doing your first epoch alpha will be 1
over 1 plus 1 times alpha 0 so your
learning rate will be zero point one
that's just your evaluating this formula
when the decay rate is equal to 1 and
the epochal on this one on the second
you pop your learning rate the case to
0.67 on the third 0.5 on the fourth 0.4
and so on
fearful evaluate well these values
yourself and get a sense that you know
as a function of your epoch number your
learning rate gradually decreases
whereas this according to this formula
up on top so if you wish to use learning
rate decay what you can do is try to
provide your values of both hyper
parameter alpha 0 as well as of this
decay rate hyper parameter and then try
to find a value that works well other
than this formula for learning rate
decay there are a few other ways that
people use for example this is called
exponential decay where alpha is equal
to some number less than 1 such as 0.9 5
times epoch num times alpha 0 so this
will exponentially quickly decay your
learning rate other formulas that people
use are things like alpha equals some
constant over
EPOC numb square root times alpha zero
or some constants cave another hyper
counter over dr.mini Bosch number P
square root 2 times alpha zero and
sometimes you also see people use a
learning rate that decreases and
discrete stats where for some number of
steps you have some learning rate and
then after a while you decrease it by
one half after a while by one half after
a while by one half and so this is a
discrete staircase so so far we've
talked about some using some you know
formula to govern how alpha the learning
rate changes over time one other thing
that people sometimes do is nanyo decay
and so if you're training just one model
at a time and the dual model takes many
hours or even many days to Train what
some people will do is just wash your
model as this training over your a large
number of days and then annually say oh
it looks like the learning rate slowed
down I'm going to decrease out for a
little bit of course this works this
manually controlling alpha really tuning
alpha by hand all by hour day by day
this works only if you're training only
a small number of models but sometimes
people do that as well so now you have a
few more options so how to control the
learning rate alpha now in case you're
thinking wow this is a lot of hyper
parameters how that select amongst all
these different options I would say
don't worry about it for now in next
week we'll talk more about how to
systematically choose hyper parameters
for me I would say that learning rate is
usually lower down or the list of things
I try setting alpha just a fixed value
of alpha and getting that to be wealthy
and has a huge in time learning rate
decay does help sometimes it can really
help speed up training but it is a
little bit lower down my list when in
terms of the things I would try but next
we want to talk about hyper parameter
tuning you see more systematic ways to
organize all of these hyper parameters
and how to efficiently search amongst
them so that's it for learning rate is
hey um finally I want to also want to
talk a little bit about local
optimal and saddle points in new
networks so you can have a little bit
better intuition about the types of
optimization problems your optimization
algorithm is trying to solve when you're
trying to train these in your network
let's go onto the next video to see that